[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 conmigo ya está en el estudio
Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa bienvenida buena
mañana de miércoles ya estamos a mitad
de semana y abrimos esta revista de
prensa con un repaso de lo que fueron
entonces las reacciones de la prensa
colombiana y venezolana respecto a este
encuentro que tuvieron en Caracas tanto
del presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro que fue a
visitar Pues a la sumó luego venezolano
Nicolás Maduro Rosa cómo lo reseña la
prensa internacional Buenos días Raúl
pues evidentemente como un hito casi
histórico porque como bien decías no es
la primera vez en seis años que los
jefes de ambos estados se encuentran en
persona la última vez el encuentro fue
entre Santos en ese momento presidente
de Colombia y Nicolás Maduro al frente
de Venezuela En todo caso empezamos por
el tiempo este medio colombiano de
tirada nacional que entre otras cosas
destaca sobre todo la buena sintonía no
la buena relación que expresaron ambos
mandatarios no de hecho citando incluso
al presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
dijo que es antihistórico que Colombia y
Venezuela se separen que alguna vez
ocurrió pero que no debe volver a pasar
porque lazos de sangre no suenen y bien
entre los temas que abordaron pues
comercio migración seguridad o economía
entre otros que dice el espectador rosa
el espectador hace una video en el que
destaca tres puntos de esta reunión de
este encuentro en primer lugar la
reconciliación de Venezuela con el
sistema interamericano de derechos
humanos Esto según un artículo en el
país que veremos más adelante era una
condición sine Quan o no que imponía el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro para
que tuviera lugar este encuentro en
persona también la voluntad no expresada
ayer por el presidente venezolano de
reintegrarse a la comunidad andina de
Naciones algo que sin embargo deberán
aprobar los otros miembros de esta
organización de desarrollo
tutorial no recordamos que forman parte
de esta comunidad también chile Perú
Bolivia Ecuador y bien a Colombia
evidentemente por otro lado también la
protección de la amazonía ambos
mandatarios plantearon llevar una
postura común ante la Cope 27 y esperan
también que Brasil se una no a este
principio de acuerdo a esta idea a este
nuevo plan para proteger la amazonía no
que Petro describió como un Pilar
fundamental de la existencia humana Y es
que Brasil recordemos dentro de sus
fronteras contiene más del 60% de la
selva amazónica Y por último la relación
entre Colombia y Venezuela no un
restablecimiento que pasa por a muchas
áreas después de que ambos países
restablecieran a sus relaciones
diplomáticas tras la llegada de Pedro de
Petro al poder y entre otras cosas viene
el hecho de abrir totalmente la frontera
el 1 de enero de 2023 y también que
ambos países vuelvan a colabo Raúl en
términos de inteligencia no porque
señaló el presidente colombiano que la
intención no es golpear al obrero del
narcotráfico sino a los dueños del
capital que es a los que nunca se ha
golpeado Bueno vamos ahora con el
universal rosa
en Venezuela destacan la cooperación
también en términos de empresas
petroleras no en términos de pedevesa o
pekeven y monómeros que atención era una
empresa que petroquímica no que Petro
quería recuperar finalmente no pudo ser
posible pero sí consiguió ciertos a
descuentos en fertilizantes para el
campo colombiano y Bien también quería
mencionar una parte no un párrafo de la
declaración conjunta que ambos
mandatarios firmaron y que consta en
este artículo a través de un enlace al
Twitter de Nicolás maduro bien para
mostrar un poco la sintonía no esta
nueva sintonía de las relaciones entre
ambos países vecinos y es inspirados en
el legado histórico la unión y en el
espíritu de confraternidad que nos
heredó el padre libertador Simón Bolívar
y en la hermandad de nuestros pueblos
que ahora son geográficamente y
políticamente dos repúblicas soberanas
pero históricamente una sola nación
bolivariana vamos ahora con ese artículo
del país el que estaba hablando
anteriormente exactamente un artículo
firmado por Juan Diego Quesada que
destaca que la última vez que se vieron
no a ambos mandatarios fue en el funeral
de Hugo Chávez y que esta es la primera
toma de contacto de una relación que
digamos será difícil ambos mandatarios
lo saben pero que no tiene marcha atrás
y que ambos son conscientes de esto no
lo que decíamos que Colombia ha cambiado
de perspectiva respecto a Venezuela y
que en lugar de aislarlo quiere
integrarlo no al sistema internacional
lo que decíamos Venezuela Caracas acepta
reintegrarse en este sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos de la
oea lo que destaca el país significará
que un tribunal internacional podrá
enmendar sentencias de la venezolana que
según la ONU no es Imparcial recordemos
una organización que abandonó Hugo
Chávez en 2013 y quisiera leer un
artículo un párrafo de este artículo del
país que dice son dos políticos que se
necesitan maduro desea reincorporarse a
la escena internacional y Petro quiere
construir aquí su imagen internacional
en un lugar en el que de verdad puede
influir después de años de acusaciones
de que en realidad él era un chavista
encubierto trata de jugar al papel de
negociador con una fecha en el Horizonte
2024 cuando deben celebrarse unas
elecciones presidenciales en Venezuela
la comunidad internacional y Petro desea
que la oposición pueda disputarles unas
elecciones justas a maduro y también
recordemos que Petro a Petro le interesa
también el papel clave de Venezuela en
las negociaciones con la guerrilla del
eln nos quedamos en el país pero junto
con afuera de Sao Paulo nos centramos en
el momento poselectoral de Brasil rosa
para finalizar Exacto rápidamente La fue
la de Sao Paulo dice que ha sido tardía
reaccionan de bolsonaro ha tardado
prácticamente 48 horas pero que
finalmente ha sido un reconocimiento
tácito de que no puede hacer nada para
revertirla derrota a pesar de que no
haya mencionado explícitamente anulada
Silva vencedor de las elecciones dice el
retraso en el gesto no mejoró la gestión
de bolsonaro Pero esto ya no importa y
el país en la misma línea dice que
bolsonaro puede obstaculizar en cierto
modo retrasar en la transición no de
información hacia el nuevo gobierno de
Lula pero que a la práctica no puede
impedirlo y que impugnar los resultados
que tendría como plazo hasta el 19 de
diciembre tampoco en cuestión de tiempos
impediría que Lula da Silva asumiera
tomara posesión el 1 de enero de 2023
muy rápidamente porque no quiero dejar
por fuera los datos de reporteros Sin
fronteras en el día contra crímenes
contra nosotros los periodistas
exactamente rápidamente reporteros Sin
fronteras reporta que en lo que va de
2022 50 periodistas han sido asesinados
en el ejercicio de su trabajo y el país
más mortífero para los periodistas como
hemos destacado muchas veces es México
con 12 periodistas asesinados en lo que
va de este año más que incluso en
Ucrania donde se han contabilizado 8
periodistas y el más mediático Quizás en
estos tiempos ha sido el de chirin
abogable en la cisjordania ocupada como
siempre Rosa Muchísimas gracias aportó a
la información mañana con más revista de
prensa hasta